TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
Mr. Pete LePage.
PETE LEPAGE: Hello,
Mr. Timothy Jordan.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I'm traveling
around visiting my best DA
friends.
PETE LEPAGE: Woo-hoo.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
talking about what
are you going to do
during the holidays?
Now, it's not your sort of
serious professional work.
But maybe you're going
to explore some new fun
technology, and what is
that going to look like?
PETE LEPAGE: Well,
I'm going to go play
with progressive web apps.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I bet you are.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, you
know, it's kind of fun.
There's lots of neat stuff.
You had somebody on your show.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Darren Fischer-- we
had Darren Fischer on the
show a few weeks ago talking
about progressive web apps in
his keynote at the Chrome Dev
Summit.
You should check it out.
PETE LEPAGE: The cool thing
it starts as a browser tab.
You just go www dot
whatever dot com,
and you use it like a web app.
But you can add it
to your home screen,
and the more you use it,
the more useful it becomes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Give me a couple
of the technologies involved
in progressive web apps.
Just let me know what to
search for and learn and check
out and program against.
PETE LEPAGE: So the big
one is service workers,
because service workers
enables two big things.
One, it enables you to do an
entirely offline experience,
and two, push notifications.
In the past, it always had
to be a native app that
was doing push stuff.
The web couldn't do push.
With service worker,
web can do push.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Service worker's cool.
PETE LEPAGE: Service
worker's kind of awesome.
And then the other one
is the app manifest.
You saying, hey, this is my app.
This is the information
you need to know about it.
And as long as you've
got those things
and you're served via HTTPS,
Chrome will start prompting,
hey, do you want to add
this to your home screen?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's pretty dope.
PETE LEPAGE: And you've
got a progressive web app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: If
you want to check out
more about what Pete
talks about on the show,
there's a bunch of great
links down in the show notes.
Pete, thank you for braving
the wonderful New York weather.
PETE LEPAGE: You're welcome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
let's go get warm.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah,
I like that idea.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So here I am on
another part of the High Line.
This is just as majestic
and just as cold,
and I've caught up
with my buddy, Josh.
Josh, how you doing?
JOSH GORDON: I'm doing great.
Thanks for coming to New York.
It's good to have you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hey, your welcome.
It's great to be here.
So I'm asking my best DA buds,
when you leave the office,
and you get some time
to relax and renew,
and you still want
to do some coding,
what are you going to play with?
JOSH GORDON: I am going to
relax and renew with TensorFlow.
As you heard from the awesome
[INAUDIBLE] a couple weeks ago,
TenserFlow--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: He was on
the show a couple weeks ago.
JOSH GORDON: He's phenomenal.
But TensorFlow is a new
open source machine learning
tool kit released by Google.
And specifically what
I'm going to play
is with using
TensorFlow on Android.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: If you
were to play with that,
let's say, on your
Android device,
what would it look like?
JOSH GORDON: Well, I have
an awesome demo for you.
And this is TensorFlow running
a computer vision model.
And the way this will work
is I'll activate the camera
on my phone.
Then I'll point the phone
at different objects,
and it will tell
me what they are.
For example, if I point
it at this banana,
it will say this is a
banana or this is an apple
or this is an Android doll.
And it works quite
well, all in real time,
running just on the device,
super fast, no Wi-Fi
or any kind of cloud
access necessary.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
how does it work?
JOSH GORDON: Well,
it uses something
called the convolutional
neural network.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And what is that?
JOSH GORDON: Well,
to learn about that,
I'm actually working on a series
of videos called "Demystifying
Deep Learning," and they'll be
released in a couple months.
And they will teach
you from the ground up
what a CNN actually
is and how it works.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's great.
So today they can
play with TensorFlow
by going to tensorflow.org.
And in a few months, we're going
to learn even more from you
about how to do machine
learning in their apps?
JOSH GORDON: Absolutely,
and by the way,
the tutorials on tensorflow.org
are top notch, so highly
recommend them, and you can
try this stuff out right now.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank
you for joining us
on this holiday edition
of "The Developer Show."
JOSH GORDON: Thanks for
having me, and stay warm.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.